[Music]
all right let's do some topics what do
you got i got i got a couple dude i got
a bunch of good stuff let's pick one of
yours let's do the satoshi and the paul
larue thing because they're both really
interesting
um
do you know let's do let's do which one
do you want to do first
i don't know who paula ruiz is you don't
know who paularu is okay [__] great
name though dude listen to this how much
more would i be worth if i was sean
leroux
at least triple right
and how would you respect what i get
he's also african he's from uh south
africa i think uh so ben you're nodding
a little bit like you know who this is
is that true
uh yeah i know paul larue is he's kind
of like um
uh who's the guy we were talking about
that you knew uh
he's kind of like
if if ross had been
as crazy as everyone thought but
actually like 10 times crazier that's
paula rue paul
whoa
yeah yeah i don't know
man who's this all right so he's basic
all right so paula roo he's this big old
fat disgusting guy he's like
like imagine the top of the hood yeah
imagine like have you seen south park
where they're like playing video games
and there's that fat guy on the computer
who's like eating cheetos
he kind of looks like that he's just a
total slob but he's this computer whiz
yeah google them um he's like disgusting
and
it that kind of fits the personality of
of the whole story and there's this
great book uh that i'm reading it's
called mastermind it's about him and
basically this guy always like kind of
wanted to take over the world and in
around like 2002 2003 2004 he started
this company called rx limited which
basically sold viagra and a couple other
like schedule two drugs so like no like
um
he was able to sell some opioids but not
like the famous ones things that are
considered schedule two which is just
one below between schedule one and he
created this company called rx limited
and in like three or four years it
netted him hundreds of millions of
dollars in profit
and the do you remember years ago when
you would get an email and it said like
hey we sell prescriptions click here do
you remember that like years and years
ago when you're in high school in grade
school
not really but go on let's say let me
say yes go ahead well basically and then
like maybe you remember like going to
like these websites where like just
showed tons of drugs and like you'd get
texts that says like buy drugs online
well basically he created this website
rx limited and then eventually he
started like creating so many domain
names that he created his own domain
registration system and then eventually
his network got so big he created his
own email system because he didn't want
anyone to uh hack into his stuff and at
one point he had like two or three
thousand employees
working at this place mostly filipinos
mostly working call centers and in
philippines and in israel because he
said the israeli guys were the hardest
working for the cheapest you know the
cheap the for the cheap rate and he uh
it was it was wild and he had basically
hundreds of different stores selling
drugs and the way it worked is he would
somehow convince a doctor that he was
like doing everything by the book and
technically he kind of was doing
everything by the book but it just
really quickly warped and did not but
basically he had all these doctors in
america in like minnesota kentucky
florida like these relatively small
doctors and like hey we're a
telemedicine service can you fill some
of the prescriptions that we're doing um
it's all legal and we'll just send you
the the prescriptions that we need and
you just sign off and we're gonna send
it to a pharmacy so we would send it to
a pharmacy and these local mom-and-pop
pharmacies would be like okay dr x is um
just called in this prescription i'm
gonna ship it to the patient no big deal
and so both the doctors and the patient
doctors and the pharmacists they all
thought that they were mostly following
the law they're like this is kind of
weird that i'm now shipping out i'm like
a mom and pop pharmacist and i'm
shipping out like 2 000 orders a week
like that's weird but i have no reason
to believe this is illegal and
eventually it did become highly illegal
where like he
it was just like you you didn't need it
to see any doctor to get in these
prescriptions and at one point he was
selling like 80
of all online drugs in america it was
something large ben am i missing
anything
and throughout doing this this is where
things get even crazier so like this
story in itself is already interesting
literally uh it made i believe 400
million dollars in profit in four years
one employee went to his apartment in
manila in the philippines and he said
that he saw a hundred million dollars in
cash in the house and he this guy like
didn't want the irs to see anything so
he would just transfer it into gold
because this was before bitcoin was
really around he lived in the
philippines he was an african guy so i
believe he was born in like cambodia and
then moved to south africa and then
moved to the philippines or maybe he was
like zimbabwe uh something like that but
this guy had this like grandiose
thinking where he thought that he like
he's like i owe it to the world to run
the world very grandiose thinking and so
he hires these israeli guys to run the
call centers eventually he hires these
ex-israeli army guys to be his
bodyguards and in doing that he starts
learning a little bit about like arms
dealing and so eventually he buys
thousands of acres of land in zimbabwe
and somalia and he was like i'm gonna
raid an african nation and i'm gonna set
up like a country and i'm gonna have my
own i'm gonna be the leader of of a
small african nation and hopefully
eventually uh a much larger nation like
some crazy [__] and
it expands to the point where he's now
an arms dealer so he's selling guns to
different parts of africa he gets in
trouble for selling missiles to iran
like this guy gets into some crazy stuff
he's killing people along the way he
makes relationships with colombia drug
lords and trades drugs uh pills for
cocaine and he starts selling 100
million worth of cocaine and he was
doing all of it almost almost all of it
behind a computer
and eventually he gets caught now he's
got he recently in like three or four
years ago was sentenced to 25 years in
prison uh and that doesn't include what
he's uh convicted for in the philippines
so after he gets out if he gets out he's
gonna go straight to the philippines in
the us or he's in the u.s but because
he's like basically a drug lord they
won't say where he is and so you could
online you can barely find any pictures
of him other than one picture of his mug
shot and that's the only pictures that
you the one where he looks like really
big that's his mug shot that's the only
picture that i've really seen of him
recently and uh the guy
it's just this is it's one of the
craziest books i've ever read and
what i
i started talking to you about satoshi
because a lot of people think they're
like well we don't i don't i don't
really there's not a ton of evidence of
those that he uh invented bitcoin but he
was talking about like creating a
digital currency early on when he was
arrested satoshi quit blogging and you
could read a lot of this guy's emails
and that's really interesting and that's
kind of how i got to the other topic of
satoshi where you can like read all his
old blog posts but this guy it's
incredibly fascinating he would have
been an awesome business person had it
not been for you know going the wrong
route but it's a crazy book what was in
the emails
you just see him commenting with people
so he was actually like a really good
writer for a little while and he even uh
this guy is so interesting he wrote
guest posts i believe for the washington
post under a pseudonym talking about
like the future of money and like all
these weird economic stuff but he uh he
was somewhat eloquent and but in person
he was uh brutish he was an [__] he
was disgusting he would just they would
go to mcdonald's and he wouldn't even
talk to his employees he would kind of
tell him to f off he wasn't very
pleasant to be around
and uh but in the emails he wrote pretty
pretty nicely actually what do you say
ben they found 500 pounds of cocaine on
his yacht when it crashed which was
worth like a hundred million dollars
[Laughter]
and he also owned a logging business in
somalia at one point he was like i'm
gonna create a business that will fend
off so basically all the western
countries driving through somalia if
they want the pirates not to talk to
them i'm going to be the go-between and
i'm going to get money from them and i'm
going to pay the pirates off and take a
little bit of profit he owned uh he
owned that business he also was in the
mining this guy did like at one point
the d.a the district of attorney of i
believe new york said we think this is
the most dangerous and powerful man in
the world
and all of it was done on peter and he
his his he was very early in all this
like he's very kind of in the same
ballpark as a lot of the crypto guys and
like some of his ideas even though he
was a criminal were like totally on
point with the bitcoin stuff so it's
super fascinating
yeah there's an article that says how
the case for why he might be satoshi i
haven't read it yet but when you're
talking i just pulled it up
you say he did it all behind a computer
but and my research on this is old i i
was looking at the story like a year ago
um but didn't don't i remember a story
about him like throwing someone off his
yacht and having people shoot them in
the water or something like that
yeah but
in that particular story he wasn't there
but he did kill a lot of people think
that he did kill one so throughout the
sean he had his hitmen he had hitmen
that are now arrested and they like kind
of spilling the beans he had hitmen that
would kill people and there are a few
occasions where they think he actually
is the one who fired the bullet so he
and he did travel so he would go to
africa he would go here but he the guy
had like 3 000 employees and most of the
employees had no idea who he was and
even there'd be times where he'd be
managing um so basically he had two
israeli brothers running this call
center in israel with like 300 employees
and they had never met paul and paul
would talk to them via email
you know as employees and it's kind of
like interesting because like anonymous
work is something we've talked about but
that's pretty much how it was so some of
his employees had no idea who he was so
in a sense it wasn't all behind a
computer but a lot of it was behind the
computer
this uh this article i pulled up about
him it says
uh he's the jeff bezos of of organized
crime and it says he's the uh he's the
digital el chapo uh because he was
moving so much weight he was he was
giving up for adoption by his birth
parents that rejection haunted him and
then it says um
he was you know transformed himself into
a programming genius who developed
encryption software like e4m in the 90s
he founded rx limited which was the
black market for pharmaceuticals he was
raking in 250 million dollars a year
selling drugs weapons and murder for
hire on the dark web
yeah well that i think that actually the
dark web thing is actually confusing
because a lot of the stuff that he was
doing was before tor was even around so
a lot of stuff he would do it wasn't
even on the dark web and like this whole
thing about spamming email he was
actually one of the originators of that
and so he uh somehow hacked into a farm
a pharmaceutical company and stole
something like hundreds of millions of
email addresses and he would spam these
guys like crazy and the reason why he
bought all these domain names is a
domain would get banned then you would
switch i don't mean so it was incredibly
complex what he did and he uh before he
turned to the dark side he founded a uh
or he built like a small open source
product that helped encrypt things and
uh it eventually turned into this thing
called truecrypt which i actually think
that thing is big but uh so like the guy
was pretty genius he was amazing it says
his first murder was he took his head of
security he said hey come to my house in
the philippines and dig a hole i'm gonna
bury a safe filled with millions of
dollars and then the guy dug the hole
and then he shot him with the machine
gun right after that that was the first
his first taste of murder and then
there's another there's another story
where they they took a guy out into the
ocean and they go where let's just have
a a talk on our yacht and they throw the
guy in the ocean and they drive away so
he gets he freaks out and then he comes
back
and he shoots all next to the guy and he
goes oh no no just so you know i didn't
miss i'm just trying to keep the sharks
away
because i want to talk to you and i need
to know are you stealing from me and if
you tell me quickly i'll kill you now if
you don't tell me i'm just going to
shoot you in your leg and i'm going to
drive off
and so like you the guy was really
hardcore
yeah he makes you know whatever the wolf
of wall street look like a small puppy
um this guy's insane okay wow never
heard of this guy either how did you
hear about him how'd you how did you
find out so
when i tweeted out that i love like
crime books and i i think i i just
finished uh i forget what i just
finished but someone suggested this book
called mastermind and it's by this
journalist that worked at wired magazine
and i've been reading this book and it's
freaking crazy and even though this guy
what he did was wrong it does like
actually inspire me to like live a more
adventurous life
well i'm like reading this and i'm like
why i'm the same way i'm the same way
i'm like why am i so fascinated by this
like this is why i don't like watching a
wolf of wall street i'm like why does
this excite me so much like i i'm
beginning to normalize this in my head
and think this is okay i can't watch
this anymore but i do think that there
is a thing where like i can i need to
have a little bit more adventure you
know you could use it for good but you
know i read it and i'm like intoxicated
by it
do you get that way yeah i think that's
why people love movies about you know
prison you know prison breaks or they
love it about bank heists and like why
people play you know video games that
have violence in them it's like
there's
definitely like a part of us that you
know this stuff appeals to
and like you know if you can get that
outlet by just reading the book or
watching the movie or playing a video
game like good because you know you
didn't translate in that that kind of
deep-rooted desire for like you know
either adventure thrill power
um you know
you know whatever it is doesn't have to
like spill into your your normal life
then
yeah and it it like inspires me a little
bit in the sense of like man living life
on the edge is crazy i don't want to go
to prison but you should just add that
to your bio you know top inspirations
pablo escobar
ross all right yeah
so
you're heroes
and one of the reasons why it's
interesting is
the the cool thing about criminals
online is that you can read their
correspondence so like they got they
when they arrested him he had his
computer open and so they were able to
like see a bunch of stuff
and that's i really love that this era
about criminals and uh how you can like
see it happening and that got me
interested in these satoshi posts so
basically if you go to like uh if you
just google like satoshi you know the
guys created bitcoin if you go to
satoshi blog post you can i was reading
all of his blog posts and
what i found to be really fun is you go
to his first blog post where he talks
about introducing bitcoin and you can go
to the the forum is still up and you i
spent about an hour looking at all the
people commenting on it and googling all
of them and seeing what they're doing
and what they're up to and you could see
them like reply like hey satoshi you
know this is actually a really good idea
i've been tinkering with this i went
ahead and purchased 500 bitcoins just to
try it out
you know what i mean it's really
fascinating the first few comments i
think weren't uh like i think if i
remember correctly
the original comments like it's not like
this thread blew up and people were
instantly like
genius you know this is a breakthrough
this is a genius idea right like that's
not what uh no it was like this is cute
right and so like like literally the
first comment so um so you know there's
you know sep halsberger says great stuff
this is the first real innovation so
this guy recognized it for what it is
this is the first real innovation
uh in money since the bank of england
started to issue promissory notes for
gold in the vaults which became
banknotes i believe an open source
currency has great potential a bit like
google has become the default search
engine for many of us
and then like there's some people who
are like you know i have questions about
how it works and then there's like hal
finney who i think how finney got the
first transaction like um
satoshi sent it to him and i think he
had the most questions
about it
which is why some people think hal
finney was satoshi nakamoto
um and i think he was also the first one
to like write out the like the total
addressable market for it i remember
reading that one time where he's like
well if this got adopted like you know
each one of these coins is gonna be
worth like over a million dollars right
and he like broke down why which is like
you know
it's hard to even discuss that now today
that sounds weird imagine 2009 you're on
a forum and you know
somebody posts this thing about how
they're creating you know the new world
money and you're like well you know that
means this little
random thing that i could go mine on my
computer you could just send me 5 000 of
these right now like
yeah that each one of those could be
worth a million dollars and to me that
was really impressive the people who
saw it for what it is which is like you
know a true innovation something that's
great something that could catch on
i'm pretty blown away by that me too i
think it's amazing when i read it i feel
inspired and i think that's why i got
obsessed a little bit with paul larue is
like just these people who just have
this self-belief and vision even if it's
like a horrible vision and go out and
like do it it's and they're in the
depths of the internet it's really
interesting and this and and i've been
reading all of the uh
satoshi's forum posts and just seeing
these just like you can click and see
these guys profiles like they're wearing
fedoras and like crocodile duddy hats
like they're the nerd the nerdy or the
nerd the guys who like i would dismiss
and be like oh what are you like okay
nerd like you're smart but like you're
just outlandish i can't believe anything
uh that you're doing you read this and
they're incredibly thoughtful and they
like are taking it seriously right off
the bat and i admire that and uh it's a
really really fun thing to read
yeah i think it's on the you know who i
think it was like a forum
it was called the p2p foundation or
something like that was the the original
forum that this was on it was like a
ning forum or something like that and so
you know the people who hang out in
these types of forums right they're
obviously like pretty hardcore either
into peer-to-peer into cryptography into
these different subjects and so you know
um hanging out at the fringes hanging
out i gave a talk recently
for um
a bunch of people in the midwest they
like zoomed me in and they were like we
just want you to talk to our group
and one of them asked they go you know
you said something about like
surrounding yourself with interest you
know like interesting people how do you
do that like what do you actually do to
do that
and i basically told him i go
um i'm a pretty like normal person like
i like catchy songs by katy perry right
i don't have like great music dates i
like if something's in the top 40 i'm
like oh that's pretty good you know like
it's not like i have this like this nose
for the next big thing but there are
people who who have that that's their
superpower and so
i used to make fun of those people
because every time they would do
something weird i'd be like oh weird and
then i point out how weird it is and i
would kind of laugh at it and they
didn't really care because they weren't
trying to be cool anyways um
like i remember my in college the guy
who lived next door to me
uh scott tawfiq he was i walked in he
was like playing a video game starcraft
or something like that and he like
turned to talk to me and the game kept
going and i was like
are you even playing like you just you
just this is a computer and he was like
he's like yeah i'm just he's like no i'm
watching uh the match from last night in
korea
i'm like what you're watching somebody
else play video games is back in you
know what's been
2006 or something like that and he's
like yeah i'm watching a recording of
this game this match that happened in
the korean server and i'm like
dude
say five more lame things like yeah than
that like i'll give you a hundred
dollars if you can say
tell me you're a virgin without telling
me you're a virgin exactly i was just
like oh okay like never coming in this
room again and then later like you know
fast forward 10 years or whatever sell
sell or our company gets acquired by
twitch and all of a sudden my title is
like director of esports or something
like that and he calls me he's like you
[__] he's like oh mr esports now
huh and i was like yeah dude it's a big
thing you know you you were on top of it
and like i sort of you know was
embarrassed because like it was so true
i was making fun of that behavior then
sure enough that becomes like such a you
know like a billion it was a
multi-billion dollar idea i was watching
other people video games and so i i've
kind of learned the hard way many times
after making myself make a fool out of
myself on that where like now when i
hear something weird i'm just
immediately like let me pull up a chair
so tell me like why do you do this do
other people do this how often do you do
this like and the weirder it is the more
i want to lean into that phenomenon
because i know like it's just a matter
of time until i discover that this is
like a totally normal behavior it's like
oh you only drink
soy lent for all your meals like oh
interesting are there is there community
people who do this yeah we're called you
know whatever biohackers there's a
subreddit with like tens of thousands of
us like oh interesting you know you can
start to see that the you know the
future is is already here it's just not
everywhere and like how do you how do
you get closer to the future you just
find people who already live in the
future do weird stuff and then you don't
judge them in fact you just like
complete have the opposite reaction i
used to have and this exercise of
reading these old blog posts and all the
commenters is
i think you just kind of put it in a
little more elegant eloquent way but
that's exactly what's happening is like
you're seeing like i'm trying to pattern
recognition is kind of a stupid buzzword
but like you're trying to like see like
well i know for sure that a this sounds
silly at first and b it worked so like
what does this like pattern of like
people just missing and like coming up
with like and how do i not make that
same mistake the guy that you talked
about uh what was the form called the p
uh
yeah i i so i on the very bottom of the
forum it says like about and you could
like read who the owner is and he's just
a professor in berlin or something like
he's just a guy
and uh it's pretty fascinating i'm like
man like all these people were
it's it's
it it's like you know they
they they
that's kind of weird to say but they're
like they were around when jesus was
around like you know like they like saw
this like thing that like potentially
changes
what the next thousand years or the next
500 years of history and they like saw
it and i think that's really fascinating
so dude i put this in the milk road i
don't know if you saw this thing about
like so peter
the big bitcoin conference just happened
in miami yeah yeah that was a really
that was really good uh on friday you
did that right yeah i did that one on
friday that was that nice rated one yeah
that killed it that was so good but did
you i don't know if you saw the clip i
think i had linked to the clip in there
of so peter thiel goes he gives his talk
at the bitcoin conference in 2022 just
happened and he
before he comes out they played on on
the big screen this video that i had
seen before i think i even talked about
it on here once but there's this video
i've watched a ton of old peter two
videos there's a video of him giving a
talk in 1999
and he's talking about the idea of a
currency not owned by uh by the
government and basically it's like this
two minute clip of peter till basically
describing bitcoin without saying the
word bitcoin and he didn't know how it
would work but he's like
you know
the world needs a currency that's not
controlled by you know the central banks
of different countries blah blah blah
and i think paypal originally that was
their vision was to create they used to
have shirts that sent one currency to
rule them all or something like that it
was like this i original idea of paypal
was to create one global virtual
currency and they shifted away from that
later like and he at this talk he goes
yeah we went to something that was more
practical and it kind of worked but like
it was less ambitious and like you could
tell you kind of like regretted it which
is like we before we wanted to create
our own financial system
and then like
we said really hard and we settled on oh
paypal it's a payments network that like
it works with your existing bank with
the existing dollar currency and with
your to send to somebody else's existing
bank so we're just like a funnel to like
funnel the money through and like yeah
that was cool but like
um
man this other thing was the big idea
and bitcoin kind of proved that that was
the big idea you know later on but him
giving that talk in 1999 to me is so
crazy like that's one of the greatest
like calls i've ever seen of just
calling it what's gonna happen why it's
gonna happen and in that talk he's like
he's like uh you know this currency will
live on your cell phone outside of a
bank um
you know smartphones are gonna be a
thing and then you think about it it's
like oh 1999 man iphone came out in
2007. so he's predicting smartphone he's
like we're already seeing the adoption
of smartphones in finland and he's also
just banned
he gave a five-year term and you're like
he it was ten but he got it right yeah
he's like a billion he's like there will
be a billion smartphone devices in the
next five years it took ten years but
like a billion device like there was
never a there was never a billion user
product
like there weren't a billion people who
had computers ever um there weren't a
billion people i don't even think that
used televisions i think the cell phone
was the first thing where it was like a
smartphone was like the first thing
where
a billion people had this product so of
course if you launch an app that works
your addressable market is a billion
people who could download your app like
immediately like it's kind of an
overlooked fact about why mobile was so
big it's just like well there wasn't
ever a billion people who could have
used your product before this like your
restaurant could never serve a billion
people your store could never serve a
billion people like mcdonald's couldn't
even serve a billion people no matter
how many locations they opened like the
cell phone was really the first thing
that was able to do that you know that
quickly
and um and so he's you know when he was
talking about like smartphone adoption
is rising in finland i'm like
who even pays attention what's going on
in finland dude like if i ask you right
now if i say point to finland on a map
could you think you could point to
finland on a map right now like
me neither and so like finland denmark
and like holland and sweden are all the
same thing
yeah exactly yeah like i don't know dude
it's like that's where white you're
clean and you're nice i get it like
it's and so like i thought about that
i'm like oh no wonder the people who
were hanging out with peter thiel went
on to do like something pretty hold on
what
hey ma sorry
my bad there's some like random guy like
knocking on my window all right sorry go
ahead so i was saying that you know it's
no wonder that people hanging out with
peter thiel ended up going on to do
amazing things right like if you've ever
heard of the paypal mafia it's like
yeah like people who worked at paypal
went on to create youtube and linkedin
and tesla and spacex and yelp and a firm
and like i think there's like over 10
billion companies that came out of the
paypal mafia
and um like kiva like one of the best
non-profits came out of that and so it's
like
dude why is that it's because you're
hanging out with a bunch of people who
are already thinking about the future
living in the future they're all weird
nerds and i remember the the one of the
co-founders of paypal max levchen he had
this thing where he's like he was
interviewing somebody and the guy
started like talking about how like he's
like yeah i love to play pick up hoops
he's like we're not hiring this guy he's
like why he's like oh my god he's like
he's like nope no great programmer i
know plays pick up basketball
dude well that's what we said about the
guys who are doing icos we're like dude
if your teeth are really white and you
got abs and if you have a ferrari and if
your last name is also a first name
that's four out of four you out like
like if your last name is sure or john
like you're out like no saint john's
exactly
and so you know these things like i mean
you get canceled today for being like
i'm not going to hire somebody who plays
pick up hoops um but like and i think
they even said something back then they
go your goal as a startup is to
basically build a cult
and they're like the more cult-like you
can make your company the better and
like that's not popular i think they've
all they don't say that stuff in public
anymore because now they're like you
know bigger public figures but like i
think that startup advice is actually
fantastic startup advice now the cult
doesn't need to be all people of the
same race or gender or anything like
that it's like
people who are all believe like
religiously in the mission and then
people who kind of behave in a way
that's like
they're willing to work way harder sleep
in the office like you know they're
willing to go to bat for this thing
because you know they're like members of
a cult they sort of have lost their own
personal identity to the greater
identity of the group that is like a
pretty hard force to bet against and
beat
dude this gets me inspired how how do
you think
this was actually a third topic i was
going to ask you how do you think
guys like peter thiel who i i don't know
his background but i think it was pretty
modest
uh how do people like him
like how are they right so often
or
i mean do they just make a ton of
guesses and they're only read a couple
times but it
i i don't understand like that idea of
thinking i think i think big and then i
like talk to or listen to him i'm like
oh i'm like i'm i'm nobody
yeah uh dude when you hear him talk it's
like when you're in a plane that takes
off and all of a sudden the houses start
to look like little toys and the people
start to look like ants the cars look
like you know little flex it's like
that's how that's how my brain feels
when i hear peter thiel talk i'm like oh
i am a small simpleton you know i'm a
single cell organism compared to this
guy in terms of just like
where my brain goes how how much
conviction i have around my own original
thoughts because like that's his thing
right like he's all about being a
contrarian and um you know
i think jeff bezos said this about peter
thiel he goes yeah that's the thing
about contrarians they're usually wrong
you know and uh somebody else said like
you know peter's constantly predicting
sort of like the end of the world in the
market crash and like you just remember
it the two times he was right in the 20
years and like the four times he was
wrong it just seemed like he was a
little bit late on his prediction and um
so i think there's definitely something
to like you know being wrong a bunch but
it's like when you're it's more like
when you're right you're right in a
major major way and i think he was right
about paypal in a major way i think he
was right about
uh facebook in a major way right he was
the first investor in facebook he bought
a 500 about a 10 stake in facebook for
500 grand all right so like that was the
best investment of the decade i think
you know like at that time and so you
know he was writing a major way about
that
um
you know the last time he kind of went
on tour he was right about two very
contrarian things one was trump where
all of a sudden like he was the only guy
in silicon valley that was like publicly
supporting trump when spoke at the at
the convention was like we need donald
trump to be president and at the time
was sort of like donald trump was the
underdog he was not supposed to win and
like peter gill picked that horse pretty
early i thought that was kind of
impressive
and like also he gets off on it being
contrarian you could tell uh and then
the other one that he was right about
was uh when he created the teal
fellowship so he basically
went on which he had which was laughable
at first and he had he had this talk
where he goes and he goes
uh university you know college education
is a bubble it's the greatest bubble
since the housing crisis this is right
after the the housing bubble popped he's
like the next bubble is college
education people like
who goes against education like go ask a
hundred out of a hundred politicians
parents anybody who's
not pro education and like he was the
first guy to be like college education
is a complete bubble and he explained
why it was a bubble that like you know
people go for basically this like
certificate this he goes up he goes it's
an insurance product partially because
uh you know it's an insurance for you
know parents buy for their kids so that
they don't fall through the cracks of
society he said it's like uh
a certification product you know you
don't go there to learn you go there to
get your certificate um and so he's was
calling out college and then he created
the teal fellowship which was kind of a
genius move because
he put up i think at the beginning two
million dollars
but that two million dollars was like
200 million dollars of free publicity
for himself because he he made it bold
where he's like not just like here's an
alternative to college for people who
don't want to go he's like well explain
what it is
it was he came out he goes i will pay
you a hundred thousand dollars to drop
out of college
and it's like oh [__] you know like keep
this man away from my children like you
know it was like a
seem like a not good thing to do and
then he explained why he's like college
is you know a complete bubble but then
how do we get his money back from that
again
i think he invested in the projects i'm
not sure well for example ethereum came
out of that which is a 300 billion
dollar product uh which is kind of
ironic because he doesn't he never
claims victory on it and in fact at the
bitcoin conference he kind of [__] on
ethereum which is a bit weird um
so you know i don't know why he's i i
would think he'd be taking a victory lap
because like vitalik being a a teal
fellow was like
the total validation of the teal
fellowship but i think figment
yeah he's a he's one of those guys
and about two or three more i've
invested in about three of them maybe
yeah um yeah i heard kind of mixed
things about the project the program
itself but like there's no doubt like
good stuff came of it like if if just
figma came out of it the program was
like a win you know like i'd say 10
billion dollars came out of it yeah
dude and so you know and there's many
others there's a bunch of other winners
that have come out of it too but like
so this guy's like been uh you know
contrarian and right many many times
it's very impressive to me it's more
impressive to me than
people like obviously he's very
successful so it's not even like that or
success but if you just showed me one
person who's very successful and another
another person who has like an original
thinker who's right when they go against
the grain
damn i'm more i have a lot more respect
and admiration for the person who was
went against the grain and had an
original thought that was right yeah and
uh it's inspiring i um i was reading
today and it said that uh this is like
kind of a weird a weird tangent but
jared kushner all right you know jared
kushner
uh
yeah so who so who is he he's he's
married to the trump or his brother is
married to the trump
uh so there's jared and josh josh is the
younger one i think he's like 35. he's
married to a model and he runs thrive
which is a vc thing that's like
immensely successful his brother is
jared who i forget his title in the
white house but he was like trump's
right-hand man and he's married to
ivanka
yeah and like a lot of people think he's
evil he probably is a little bit he kind
of has like a skeleton vibe to him like
a skeletor the the villain and he-man or
whatever it was so he's like kind of has
like a vibe to him but he just announced
that uh like a few months after leaving
the white house uh he
he founded a
three billion dollar private equity fund
and
like regardless you put politics aside
um like it's crazy that that's just like
your thing like you you added that you
you ended one like like when i end a job
i take like a a lot of people take like
a three week vacation and they go start
another job that's like 20 percent
higher in salary and a little bit better
title
and like he just like was like oh you
know i'm like i've got some free time
now i'm gonna like you know be bop boop
just do this thing it's a three billion
dollar fund and like i find that to be
it's the same thing of like i feel like
an ant and you are not that
you know what i mean
yeah exactly um
i i know exactly what you mean it does
beg the question of like
you know why why do i not go bigger and
also
um
you know is there a reason that i don't
go bigger like is there a reason sam
that you don't go
create a three billion dollar private
equity fund there's there's two reasons
the first is fear so like it is scary to
do that to like raise like for to raise
outside failure yeah to raise outside
money and [__] it up that's bad but
number two i do think that there is i
don't know if peter thiel has this but
elon musk for sure has this did you read
that article in the new yorker or new
york times where he describes his life
he's like basically he was talking to
the interviewer and he was starting to
cry in the interview and he's like he's
like you don't want to be me yeah he
basically said he's like i missed my
brother's wedding i or he was like i was
about to miss it but i flew in at the
last minute i saw immediately got on the
plane he was like there was like a time
a few weeks ago where for five days i
didn't leave the factory i didn't see
the sunshine i don't see my children uh
i had a birthday but no friends came and
said happy birthday to me because i was
running around uh the factory and like
i'm lonely and i'm pretty sad to be
honest and frankly death i look forward
to it as a way of relief that's like
what he said he said all that yes
and uh
like
the whole thing bro yeah take a
just nap it just try it
a little advice from one brother to
another
well and it's like so i think there's
one aspect where it's like well i don't
want to like
be this like
the slave to this computer and the
machine like f that um and i want to
live life but i do think that they're
and i i i haven't formulated this entire
this thought entirely i do think there's
a world where you can go big and have
some work-life balance so
actually so
do you think that's true
yeah of course of course it's true uh
you just got to decide your terms right
like um and as soon as you decide those
terms watch you'll figure out a way to
make it happen or you'll find people who
make it happen
i am so anti there's one way to win or
there's even one definition of winning
like that's if i could just be the anti
one thing that's the thing i'd be most
anti because
i used to fall into the trap i'd see
somebody doing something one way or i
hear advice that makes sense
and then i'd kind of like
this like later in life i found the
counter factual it's like wait but this
guy doesn't do that but this this that
lady did both right like so hold on
if both is an option then i'm taking
both every day of the week it's only
when i accept that both is not an option
i fall into this trap of misery around
picking one or the other right of like
lifestyle and
and like you know ambition so
um so i definitely think you do both i
played this game though so i have two
games that i play about any project that
i'm doing this is kind of like my i kind
of exact coach myself and i really
always ask two questions i go i go for
the first question is
if
and i asked this other founders tube
which is if i was to meet up with you
you know if we hung out 12 months from
now we're grabbing a beer
and i'm like hey what happened with that
thing man what happened with trends that
was such a cool idea like what went
wrong
what do you think is the most likely
thing you're gonna say in that moment
where you're like ah dude
here's what you know here's where we've
we messed up or here's what we turned
out here's what we thought that we
turned out we were turns out was wrong
um so it helps you identify the riskiest
part of your business either the
riskiest assumption you're making the
thing you need to go validate or the
risky path that you're going on where
you're cutting off other options or
you're not you know you're really
leaving yourself you know one move away
from failure so i always ask that
question and the way i don't know why
like if you just ask somebody straight
up like what's the biggest risk in your
business they answer it one way it's
like but there's other way with i think
people can relate to which is like
if i see you a year from now we're just
grabbing a beer hanging out it's like i
just let's just presume already it's
gone wrong
what was the cause of death you know
like what do you think was the reason
that so that's one the second one the
game we played yesterday with the milk
road um it was
it's called the the why the [__] aren't
you game and it's basically it's like
it's like either why the [__] are you or
aren't you which is like
what part if i was just an objective
person looking at what we're doing would
i say why the [__] are you guys doing
this like why aren't you hiring somebody
to do that it's taking you five hours a
day and like you should
totally you could could you not find
somebody to do that part or like
why aren't you
like why aren't you at this bitcoin
conference like aren't you building a
crypto product like shouldn't you be at
this event
um like there's just like this series of
like why are you or why aren't yous and
it's like why the f aren't you which
kind of distills it down into like
what's the obvious good idea or bad idea
like good idea we're not doing or bad
idea that we are doing um
that i would criticize about ourselves
and we both came up with a list of like
three things and it became like oh wow
we should just correct those now uh
rather like so then what's your answer
why aren't you going bigger
assuming that you're not going big which
is not a fair a fair assumption but for
the sake of discussion
yeah um
so i i wouldn't say why am i not going
bigger like the jared kushner question
you mean or the questions i was asking
just now the jared kushner question um
because i want to have you know
enough
meaning i want to have a i want to be
able to know what is enough and i want
my vision of success to be bigger than
just what's going on in my business so
it's like to me if you said paint a
picture of what winning looks like
it's not just a number in an account
right or a number in my sales dashboard
it's like
a
like i talk about this all the time it's
this perfect tuesday it's like my normal
day is perfect for what i want and that
includes like just like right after this
i'm going to go work out with my trainer
in my home gym like that's a part of my
perfect tuesday and if my business then
requires me to not have time to do that
and i'm like
getting fat or whatever or it doesn't
provide me enough money to be able to
afford that then it's not winning right
um it's like you know being able to like
take my daughter to swim class like
things like that like those are part of
what winning looks like to me
and so i'm just not gonna like
deviate from that i'm only gonna the
only thing i question is that why don't
i go bigger it's
is this picture the picture i really
want or is it outdated do i need to
update it you know and like that's the
thing i find myself being like oh man i
haven't updated this picture in a while
or there's just like a gap over here
where i don't know what i want what
would it feel like to know what i want
okay let me let me get let me figure
that out ben wilson tweeted out uh it's
a superpower to know what you really
want right ben and that was that the
tweet
uh yeah
uh really think that what did you see
her here that made you tweet that um
so what i saw is that i i've had a bunch
of people reaching out to me recently
and the people who are like hey i'd love
to connect i get so annoyed with i'm
like you just
dumped something on my plate
for me to like figure out which i just
don't want to do
whereas the people who are like hey
i really love what you do i'm also a
podcaster my podcast is this size i want
to get it to this size i'm having
trouble in these two issue areas and i'd
love to talk to you about it i'm like
great you know exactly what you want i
will
i will gladly give you that um
and uh
it's just it applies almost everywhere
in life like the guy who comes up to you
and is like hey do you have any spare
change no i don't have any spare change
hey i need two dollars and fifty cents
to get a ride home on the bus do you
have two dollars and fifty cents all
right i guess i got two dollars and
fifty cents like it's a super power in
every way
so
uh so so i like that you said that
there's a tweet that my cousin put out
yesterday my cousin he's on twitter dude
he great guy according to twitter he's
killing it i don't know i haven't talked
to him forever but like his updates i'm
like
looking like he's killing it i don't
know if he's actually i haven't caught
up but no i don't want i'm not
disrespecting him at all i'm saying like
his
like his updates are amazing he just
bought like 20 000 square feet or
something like he's on top of the game
yeah and actually he did a good job of
figuring out what he wanted bro you just
called out your cousin you should take
that back
what i love my cousin now he's great but
i i expect that as a compliment there's
a skill there's a skill especially in
his line of business which is real
estate there's a skill to putting
forward you're like putting your either
your brain on brain forward like sharing
ideas
like he put out a thing of like how i do
diligence on properties there's like a
great checklist it's like oh you're just
putting out great on point information
it makes me trust you makes me think
this guy knows what he's talking about
or if it's like like our friend nick
cooper does this too it's like he'll
send us a picture of him smoking a cigar
you know playing golf at you know 1 p.m
it's like wow this guy must be killing
it like you don't you don't get to go
out smoke a cigar and play golf you know
1pm regularly unless you're doing really
well it makes me more likely to invest
in nicuber's storage company
that i know that he's doing well in life
like some people take it as an
anti-signal like oh why isn't he working
hard to me i'm like no if you're
if you're able to like do well in life
that means you're doing something right
and like your cousin
so he tweeted something out he goes i'm
looking for like a car like a new suv
it's like kind of a general vague thing
and somebody and he then he like defined
it right afterwards so specifically he
goes
the experience the exposure experience
of a tesla the size of an escalade the
um it goes with enough room for three
car seats and a pair of golf clubs
and i was like first of all isn't it
just a more fun way to look for a car
like just to kind of imagine really what
you want and like sink into the
vividness of like
just having it and not like worrying
about the world tesla doesn't make a big
car like not like that i'm not i'm not
grounded in reality i'm living over here
in my reality of what i want he's only
he's got one kid so i'm like you know
three car seats all right he's planning
ahead like that's good
and um and i just thought it was a great
example of like specificity so so to me
a lot of people are vague in general
when they should really be being
specific and the opposite is also true
sometimes people are like man i don't
know what i want specifically and they
get tied up in a knot because of that
and my trainer had a great framework for
that he goes you got to know when to be
general and when to be specific he goes
if you
like sometimes you will tell you you
need to be more specific with what you
want that means like the type of
description my cousin gave about like
you know the lifestyle
that that what do you describe as a car
is not just a car it's a lifestyle and
um and then the second thing is like
where do you be when you be general so
my trainer i was like well what if i
don't know what i want right like if he
said what you know what's your body goal
right his personal trainer i'd be like
well i don't really have a picture of
like i don't know if i want to
like i could say oh i just want to have
like a 12 pack but i don't even know if
that's true right i'm like i don't know
exactly what i want and he's like cool
just imagine satisfaction
he goes just just first get to a place
of feeling satisfied about it where you
don't strike you're not stressed about
it anymore he goes he goes you know
relief is a very powerful emotion
satisfaction is a powerful emotion he
goes most people feel relieved one time
a day that's when they poop
he goes and now people bring their phone
in they're not even paying attention
they miss it they miss out on the one
moment of relief they were gonna have
that day he goes so i get good at
feeling relief i want to practice
feeling relieved and satisfied because
once you get good at feeling relieved
and satisfied you know what things you
want you're faster to figure out what
things you want that will lead back to
that emotion and like you're just better
at being satisfied from a meal or a
workout or whatever it is these daily
things in your life he goes let's he
goes and so we made a deal it's like i'm
i'm going to be relieved more times than
i poop today and it's like that's the
goal that's the first place
this is all from your trainer
yeah
what a smart ass dude by the way to talk
about the real what your cousin's doing
on real estate
i've talked to a bunch of these real
estate guys so and i'm friends with a
lot of them keith wasserman um
uh
chris uh fort
is that his name ford i think so uh nick
huber
moses kagan your cousin's getting in
there the strip mall guy so there's like
10 of them that are like really popular
maybe 20 and
i see the returns they're really good
and the fees that they charge are crazy
high or but like you know who cares
i've been nick's hoover's thing it's a
huge fee but like i'm getting a good
return so i don't care it this is one of
the coolest things that's happening on
twitter right now is these real estate
people are just crushing it
all through twitter it's pretty amazing
i think some of them have shared that
they bring in like
tens of millions of dollars of investor
money just off of people who are like
i'm a fan of your twitter yes uh which
is like that means if you're in real
estate like
do what my cousin's doing do what these
guys are doing like up your twitter game
because
it is going to lead to more deals and
it's going to lead to more investors in
your fund that you don't have to go
knock on doors for it's way easier to
just tweet out stuff than it is to go
like do one hour calls and seminars
webinars and in-person meetups trying to
like schmooze for a buck well i have no
idea how big nick huber this is nick
cooper from sweaty startup i have no
idea how big his portfolio is but i
wouldn't actually be surprised if it was
over nine figures and i bet you if it is
most of it came via twitter
yeah yeah i i don't i don't know if
that's i don't know exactly but i agree
with where you're where you're headed
there and also um
that's also the one reason i haven't
invested in a lot of these guys is
because the fee structure like which
might be to my detriment but like one
thing i don't fundamentally like about
real estate fees
is that they all make this like two
three percent
like acquisition fee
yeah which like you know you will buy
like a 50 million dollar thing and it's
like wow so you just banked a million
dollars in your pocket just for buying
the thing which leads you to an
incentive which is go buy more [__]
instead of being like really um
discerning between like a great property
and a good property it's like just go
accumulate and like i think nick has a
little bit of a different strategy
because he's got like a kind of like a
template now of like he buys the storage
thing he cuts out a bunch of the labor
he adds in these automations and so he
like has a playbook of how to add value
that i think not every investor says
they have i don't think they really have
it
i think nick actually does a great job
of that but like in general i would say
one reason i've shied away is because i
dislike this instead this this incentive
mismatch where like you're you're
incentivized to take my money and go buy
something because you get money today
that's guaranteed that doesn't re it
does not linked to your returns it's
only linked to your returns over a long
period of time and by then you've
already banked these acquisition fees 15
times over by the time we figure out if
these were good deals or not and i have
no idea if they're killing it because
they're skilled although many of the all
the people i've named i i've talked to
they appear skilled but i'm a novice but
also they just happen to be in the game
like starting six years ago and we're
going through like the greatest like
boom in real estate yeah so like of
course they're killing it uh but uh the
numbers are i mean i i'm an investor of
nick and i see the returns i'm like oh
yeah dude i'll give you more of but by
the way if i was nick i would i would do
exactly what he's doing i charge the
highest ps i can and be like you're
still getting a great return correct all
right fantastic if you can go beat that
return somewhere else i invite you to do
it um which is like you know he's not as
upfront about that but like that's i
would do exactly what he's doing so i
don't knock him for that i think that's
it's what i would do if i was in that
position where i know i can generate
great returns um but like on my side i
just i hesitate as an investor in that
sort of thing but maybe that's my
detriment
do you want to do more topics or do you
want to save yours for wednesday let's
do let's do a couple ideas i think
people people like ideas if you made it
to the end of the episode
congratulations alright so
let me pitch you two ideas real quick
one is called what i'm calling
copy my trip
okay so i'm booking a vacation right now
taking the family on a vacation
great idea
thank you i came up with it myself yeah
hello maybe the business idea that's
with the idea of a family vacation
so so i'm like i'm like googling i'm
like okay unless i want to go to hawaii
for example so i'm like all right i want
to go to hawaii all right which island
oh [__] no okay uh which resort oh
god here we go gotta figure out which
resort and like it matters like it's
gonna change my experience if i go to
the wrong place to the right place but
like and then i'm like and then all the
details in between like okay so if i
take my kids
do i rent a car do i get car seats do i
take the shuttle
uh
do we go on this activity is that age
appropriate and so what i want is
my wife follows all these influencers on
instagram they're like mommy influencers
and when they buy something she's like
that's a good thing i'm gonna buy that
thing too and like because she's like
look we have the same taste and like
these people they're not like they kind
of are promoting things that that like
they have a good track record like so
she's like bought a couple of things
that looked good and like paid off so
she's like now it's more trust in them
i don't get why they can't or maybe they
do this i don't know but like i don't
get why they're not just saying copy my
trip you want to go to disneyland
literally click this and like here's the
like full itinerary of like
we fly into this airport we take this
transportation to this hotel because
it's great for families for these
reasons we buy this thing this thing
whatever and like
i just get their whole trip that i can
copy and that they have basically like a
tick tock or like instagram story
version that i can just browse it to be
like oh yeah this looks fun i want to do
this like when i went on expedia and i'm
like this is awful experience it's
overwhelming here's an overwhelming list
of 100 options ranked in five different
ways that i click the [__] thing i
don't know if the reviews are real or
not i'm looking at the photos they don't
have all the photos it's like a photo
it's a static photo from like a [__]
airplane above the resort it's like dude
i just want to see like someone walk
into the room and be like oh this is
really nice the bed's good you know
there's space over here and like oh this
is cool they give you breakfast every
morning like check this out you know
like like an instagram story right so
i just think that there should be a
thing called copy my trip that anyone
could do
it'll create a profession of basically
professional travelers like people who
they go find the best path of how to
have a trip to you know bali or whatever
and like sam you might follow somebody
who's got like a fitness oriented angle
right like oh yeah they want to like
go this person likes airbnbs versus
hotels so i like aligned with them and
then it's like they went and trained at
this gym and got muay thai classes when
they went to thailand like that's
awesome that's the type of trip i want
to have so i'm going to just copy their
trip dude
we could do it we
do it for trips and weddings whenever i
like saw my wife like working so hard
this wedding i'm like dude just find
someone else and just do the exact same
thing no one will know who cares or her
younger sisters get married and i'm like
dude just do exactly what we did it was
great it was an awesome wedding and of
course obviously they don't like that
but
yeah just do the exact same thing it was
we all had a great time right uh
bachelor parties exactly
birthday parties
copy or i want to copy your work which
is like it's pinterest but just like the
whole thing's strung together so hot and
like in your lifestyle you would just do
it where like uh someone uploads an
itinerary and then you and you people
rate it and you pay them money and buy
it
yeah exactly so uh so you you don't have
to buy the trip like just by doing the
trip those people get paid mad money
from affiliates like if i booked that
resort because this person said this
resort is awesome i'm going to get a
kickback of like all the things that
they recommend no that's pretty some
perverse incentive but like
everybody kind of offers a kickback so i
think you can basically through
affiliates you can monetize this pretty
heavily for the for the creator
themselves which which is what you can
do is you could say it's not about like
creator you just recommend what you
genuinely recommend we're going to take
the entire pool of affiliate fees and
then pay it out based on whose trip got
copied even if
that hotel doesn't have to pay you to
like provide them you know what i mean i
would do something like that where are
you going
hawaii
oh that's cool
and and you haven't found it's not a
fictional example this is a real example
and you haven't been able to find a
a
no
so first i went on whatever expedia and
i was like oh god miserable don't want
to do this
okay what else can i do okay i can tweet
this out then i'm gonna get a bunch of
recommendations all right that might
work but that only works for me because
i got a big following all right i was
like how do people do this and i was
like okay let me go to i was like let me
go look at like you know an instagram
person i follow but like they're not
gonna happen to post about it that day
so like
it needs to be saved somewhere like a
link in the bio of like or like you know
one of their instagram story highlights
which is like take one of our trips and
it's like you know they always do this
like uh they do this with fashion it's
called like um
i like i buy like or some [__] like that
it's like if you like my outfits you can
go here and like you can buy any of the
items from my outfit and they get a
kickback so anything like that for trips
um
and then i went on youtube and i was
watching like okay you know
watch this like family vlog at a at one
of the resorts i'm like and they're okay
but it's like this eight minute video
and it's just that one aspect it doesn't
tell me about all the other [__] that i
could go do when i'm there and all that
stuff so anyways i just think that
that's all
elements of this happening is just
somebody should make this like an
explicit thing i think
i uh jack smith uses uh uh va's to do
stuff constantly and he he's like
at one point he even had some va's going
into hotels into different countries and
like taking pictures and sending it to
him to let him know what it was but on a
lighter
for real on a lighter outrageous thing
i've ever heard it's crazy and under a
lighter wait did he pay for them to go
on vacation like he found a local va
yeah like you would find a local person
he's like hey can you go to these three
hotels and take pictures and let me know
and then he would like show him to his
wife like all right which ones do you
want uh it was pretty good i'm calling
him jack larue from now on that's so
crazy it's kind of similar to that dude
he just sent me a picture uh and it was
him and andrew wilkinson and he's like
look i uh with they andrew and they have
their ted talk badge on and so they're
clearly at ted together and i was like
oh how funny and uh
uh
yeah and anyway he uh does this all the
time and it's actually really
interesting and there's this company
called tr flightfox you know what
flightfox is
it's is that like where you'll just
is it like somebody will book it for
it's like is it a travel agent or is it
the one where you're like
i just want something give me like the
best deal like
it's amazing so i have no idea how they
make this work so basically you go to
flightfox and you always have to click
the button that says you're traveling
for business and then a person you
select like i want to go around this i
want to go this day and i want to come
back on this time or you can even say i
want to go around this time um and then
you like leave like notes like i've got
a budget a blank or i only want first
class or uh i have to be back for a
wedding so i have to make sure there's
backup flights and someone on the other
end pops up goes hey what's going on i'm
with whatever i'm here to help you and
it's a real person and they go and they
find five to ten different flights that
fit what you want and then you finally
say all right this itinerary looks good
or you could even reply like uh this one
actually i had a change of plans i've
got to change this this and this and
they'll go and find flights for you and
they find the cheapest ones and they
know where to search for them and they
only get paid until after you booked the
flight and they just take a 50 fee i
have no idea how they make money and
then like when i was in portugal my
flight got canceled so i just logged on
and i go hey the flight you book was
canceled can you you know address it
please and they call for you and they
wait on hold for you and then you just
pay them 50 bucks it's amazing i have no
idea how this makes money or how they
can make that work yeah
get it while it lasts
50 bucks that's amazing
um that's like i i think i told you
about this thing i did once mo points
points.com it's our it's our but it's
our good buddy ramon's good buddy oh
yeah yeah yeah this was like one of the
best things uh i did it's like i booked
this call with them and so you go to mo
mo points.com just like mo points.com
and
basically it solves the problem of like
what credit card should i get and so you
just call this guy he's like all right
look like again you could just google
what credit card should i get guess what
you're gonna get like the most seo
optimized blog post in the world because
they can make so much money off
referring credit cards and you don't
know if you're really getting the real
deal and so i just called this guy 30
minutes and he's like all right tell me
about what you spend on and tell me what
you want do you want to travel like a
baller like he's like look i travel
first class worldwide just off this he's
like i'm not rich i just i use points to
do it here's how
i was like yeah i want that
and so he's like cool
get the amex gold
he's like you're gonna get four x points
on all your facebook ads for your
e-commerce thing
you're gonna get one for you one for
your wife so now you're gonna get like
two million points or whatever like in
the next year it's like then to travel
you just do this you chan you transfer
points like don't book within their
points portal because that's what i used
to do i used to go to my points thing
and be like uh rewards flights oh man i
get like half a flight for all my chase
points like no you need a transfer to
travel partners and then there you need
to like check this out you use like klm
to fly you know here here and here and
he's like just call me when you want to
book he's like for now buy the mx gold
start racking up your points when you
want to book first class worldwide just
call me again and i was like dude i feel
so taken care of this was like the best
money i've ever spent um just in terms
of the again the relief
of like ah i'm in good hands right like
the real all-state i'm in good hands is
[__] mo from mo points dude
i'm a fan i like these businesses
and i like the model of these things are
typically monetized through affiliates
but instead you're just gonna pay and
i'll give you a more honest answer i
actually i like that idea a lot
yeah exactly
me too i think it's great and um
and uh yeah people should go sign up for
that thing because if you spend a
significant amount on like for your
business
it's like it just makes financial sense
to like optimize that so you're either
gonna get the best cash back
like you know i found out oh if i use
this bank of america platinum honors
cash back card i get 2.6 percent back
cash back which is like way higher than
anybody else does that mean it basically
adds two percent to your bottom line
yeah exactly like
2.6
yeah so so you know if you're spending
you know
uh a 100 grand a month on ads which is
like very common for e-commerce just use
around round number here now you're
getting 2600 dollars a month back um
just straight to your bottom line right
like that just makes sense or you can
reinvest that a 5 000 person company or
like bcg who sends people all around the
world do they just have like a bank full
of like points
yeah i don't know what they do i
actually asked my previous startup this
i'll go i go
what do we do with all the points we
collect who gets to use those
and i i think they said that they just
cash them they just do the cashback
basically or they should convert them to
cash which is like not the most
efficient way to use it but like you
know for support this is a fair way to
do it and they just like you know keep
it uh
who keeps it
yeah where is this money i kept i used
our points at the hustle and i i flew
first class like twice a month it was
sick and then when i sold the company i
didn't have that perk anymore i was like
damn i gotta pay for a flight for the
first time in four years it sucks
that's how you gotta negotiate that in
well i kept them i got to keep all the
points we had like a million points but
i didn't get to uh i didn't get future
points
gotcha all right uh that's it i'll save
my other ideas for the next one and you
got a crime baby yeah i know
um all right thank you
[Music]
you